but that morning I went to pick up me
and my buddy might run him with the
pickup Lisa's a little appliances like
fridges buy them we just know we were
hit subcontractor okay we deliver the
walkers right yeah we'd have to go this
place we pull up at the point and this
30 air conditioners on the wall Linda
I go in I give the guy a bill no cameras
in those days either I give the guy the
Bill of Lading he gives me the pay for
the [ __ ] kick comes over hope you were
to refrigerate he carries it then the
guy gets in his car one of his buddies
and want to get hot 50 [ __ ]
air-conditioned is another thing go
Michael at the back of that thing what
are you gonna do you shut your mouth we
started putting the [ __ ] air
conditioners that thing 1020 I was at
the UPS man I took every last
air-conditioned all darzee all right
doctor refrigerate then we turn that
[ __ ] ramp and we just drove down
the boulevard hundred hours apiece an
air-conditioned it's July
it was June it was like Steve ha yeah we
sold them with the mob bet we split the
[ __ ] money
I went over to my grass house made great
teaching my football coach the running
back coach /sha and I bought a thousand
those little grand bottles of coke from
home again and I went out with my
friends I told I was in the meeting with
Joe Mary's but I took like a [ __ ]
quaalude and me and my buddies got
[ __ ] up I woke up the next one I left
his stiff so and we did the same [ __ ]
every week ok was McSorley's in out
chalet lease was in Jersey City
30 cents for now at Bama Slama and 5
cents for a mug of beer till 10 o'clock
dang at 10:01 5 so you didn't find the
friend yeah the place was vacant
it was [ __ ] crazy
we're out of here no.1 at 9:45 people
get three mugs and three drinks like
you'd see people drinking out of three
straws and [ __ ] - Wednesday was ladies
night at the Dome and Thursday there's
another ladies night
so we detect them cuz they were 50
Cent's drink so come here here's a ten
go by you
you know $7 yeah big shot to me so I saw
it down there and I apologized to I'm
sorry
in fact I sort of Wednesday down there
and I said I'm sorry about last night I
[ __ ] up so how about getting the ball
I took a peek Alicia more for villagers
like a doctor votes that hadn't been too
big Alicia forget what the guy's name
was the guy has a weird name he's
missing his stomach though why he owns a
restaurant that's a hell that's a hell
of a curse to own a restaurant and be
missing your stomach the stomach had a
dish called lobster fried the habló know
why burgers Diablo his name of this
thing was lobster Fra Diavolo yeah his
name was Johnny bother go the old pickle
Eason when he had no stomach as I'd
always be [ __ ] like I was a kid and
I'm going up there [ __ ] giving orders
cuz we get like a score and I go up
there drop money give him drink get more
a drink yeah dad don't worry about
nothing and people will get pissed was
like that scene when Belushi went to the
restaurant and Blues Brothers and I it
was white people shortly and imma go up
there with 16 gorillas so I took her on
a date up Danny brought you a dish I'm
not even exaggerating there was just big
that looked like a fish in the middle
was pasta it was surrounded by clams
mussels and shrimp to the deck God and
then Tommy I don't big lobster tails
that would crack open with red sauce on
top
oh no no no there pinga you'd put your
little thing she was in heaven she's
eating this [ __ ] thing then we get
out of there I take it down by the
binghamton the Binghamton was a boat
you're going on and have a few drinks
there was a movie theater that's where I
saw 14 hours of those bus Oh
but outside of that your memories
something that you started coke out to
have like 20 minutes you hear the rats
from the Hudson River were trying to
chip away your call it was [ __ ] at
your car come that's crazy in Freddy
boxer pseudo the whole is gone so we had
to put a [ __ ] piece of wool we went
down and make out with chicks yeah we
used to drink beers and throw them out
of the hole and people be driving that's
all that rust my buddy out of Volkswagen
with a floorboards rusted out to his
foot fell through one time on the
highway so I take this little Tricia's
her name was Lisa Tricia's it's just the
main sue she looked like Pat Benatar in
the first video of you better run with
the red oh yeah even together red and
white yeah you look like Pat he's gonna
swap and spit and I stuck eating a [ __ ]
and she started I remember she used to
put tapping powder in her [ __ ] because
will help ended up a bunch we came out
face you know I'm saying
and I [ __ ] on Facebook she ain't
dying to be varying cancer she's kicking
yeah Jersey I'm she had a shot at top
and father hit me in the face Elena
bushy she was banging on the top of the
car I was had her out there [ __ ] both
legs even with coke rock on a [ __ ] no
dick I cut her off from the dick no dick
tonight I'm dropping you off at home and
don't even look at me sideways I went
over that [ __ ] Friday night I dropped
her off like a gentleman and we may play
playing Saturday night they either
pushing Saturday night I was gonna [ __ ]
we went out went to a morning and we'll
fight the party my hand got stuck in a
barbed wire fence hot right here as I
was getting he was taking me down I
stuck my hand in the fence at wedding
that my cops came
me and my boy and heard the pieces she
had taser oh man oh there's your old man
I was a hot piece of ass for a while now
I think you named all the sadness this
was one of those [ __ ] that for six
months you look good
and for six months you show up looking
like leak so he used to call a Taser oh
man Oh big fat piano because she would
go them for [ __ ] six months she would
not eat a thing that she'd puke and
vomit this [ __ ] was fine to the bone
and stinky my friend stinking used to
giving them a luke stick for so now
we're double dating during what six
months he gave it to her like over four
years everyone so on in the winter days
you to Glen to the other room I got rich
in yellow not she's playing Catholic
girl she started to cry out oh it hurts
don't put it too close to my [ __ ] I got
a half gram my pocket I don't need this
aggravation I'm sick someone I know
listen get your life together well some
holy water on it's like it never
happened I was a gentleman oh I got a
half a G in my pocket this will get me
home and I walked home and guys as I
walked into the door where I was living
the phone rang and she goes I thought
about it let's do it like alright as she
picked me up was 7 the morning went back
to a house I gave her snap and there was
blood there was tears there was a lot of
rubber back you gotta rub their back
back I'm gonna go to hell no way but oh
well he'll it can help Hardy guilt it's
like this [ __ ] thing yeah and guess
what like a week later I saw she's very
cold to me we had a couple of like weird
discussions I was totally in love with
her when I was in love with her for
reals I would have got married at that
age like that's how in love with her I
was well after those two weeks I was
like you know what something right here
this is some beyond my control and I was
a criminal I was a criminal I had no
future and I didn't have I couldn't see
there was no future so I kind of walked
away from her a little bit I went to
Colorado I heard she was dating some
other guy in pills and party and [ __ ]
good friend of mine I never held it
never even mentioned to him that was me
or were long bother
and then I went back to New York one day
I went to a coke dealers house and there
she was looking beautiful she said oh ho
we talked a little bit and she said that
stay in touch between you and you and I
in my mind the coupe had flown already
it wasn't that I wanted a [ __ ] I
really like me I've been around the fill
ass might be 78 I'd been around but
something wasn't right
you know six months later I called her
because she was a travel agent and I
asked if she'd get me and my buddy
stinky plane ticket star why and she
goes call me tomorrow I'll give you a
quote when I quality the next thing she
does I gotta be now see I'd rather you
never call me again really yeah just
like that and I said okay que sera sera
at the age of twenty one like that one
of my biggest lessons in love [ __ ] them
send them roses and move the [ __ ] on
[ __ ] reading some podcast Ville it's
Thursday the 15th of August a beautiful
[ __ ] day to be alive the church
at what's happening now is brought to
you by Vin Sarah watches listen to me
they got an anniversary sale going on
it's on guys with Sarah watches is
having their biggest sale of the year
the more you shop the more you save the
more you save I'm sorry you could
literally save thousands this only
happens once a year everything I've been
Sarah calm is on sale nothing is
off-limits
then Sarah just dropped two new
collections a line of men's wallets and
watches they're all on sale so do me a
favor right now cordovan Sarah watches
comm to shop their biggest sale of the
year that's been several watches dot-com
with their biggest sale year remember
they offer free shipping worldwide the
Church of what's happened now is also
brought to you will by one of my
all-time favorites expressvpn
you like Joey what's expressvpn I'm
gonna tell you internet privacy is mult
dead done put away to whip the ponies
dead expressvpn runs in the background
of your computer phone
and then when you use the internet it's
just as normal as you would you download
the app click to connect and voila
you're you're protected the Ola voila
I don't know words all right it seals
your identity no location tracking and
you're totally anonymous you download
the expressvpn app on your computer or
phone
push one button and voila you're
protected now find out how you get three
months for free
Joey what are you talking to me 3 months
for free that expressvpn dot-com slash
church again that's expressvpn grab a
pen expr ESS VPN dot-com slash Church CH
you are CH for 3 months free when you
buy a one-year package who helps you out
like you uncle Joey nobody go to
expressvpn calm slash Church right now
and learn more and take back your
privacy all right
take back your privacy with expressvpn
calm Lee you know what the [ __ ] to do
check this [ __ ] wheel Church
what's happening now my man Ryan
[ __ ] cichlid
it's a pleasure to be here nursery of
your it would that be your inaugural
incarceration that was Monday morning
and that Friday at 4:30 they called so
that's what I want to ask you did you
know you were going or did you get
caught in something and taking rain oh I
knew you were going to court I knew that
I knew I was there was a good chance of
me going the prison but I didn't know
for sure till that Friday and what for
was this one for me this was for the kid
that this was kidnap they called and
they said the attorney knows that he
sitting down it was Department of
whatever turns you down Community
Corrections they turned you down so you
got two options you looking at prison or
are you looking at me putting you into a
work-release program but if Community
Corrections turns you tiny
stay in the community so he goes right
now you're looking at a ten percent
ninety ten whatever you do this weekend
have a good weekend
oh the cordon Monday at nine I got right
there i sat I got a little crushed
I took the chicken I was cooking out I
like that little grease on the side
where you put your Italian bread him I
hate it when I go [ __ ] it if this is my
last weekend I might as well make it a
good one I didn't cry I didn't freak out
I knew this day was coming
when was the question so right there I
go I'm not gonna go to jail let's talk
to his judge out of it
like that's how cocaine and our thought
about how this judge with time of this I
wasn't on a rap write a speech or
nothing I was just gonna go in there
tell him what was going on here he was
selling drugs me and my friends were
taking the drugs off the street where I
come from that's a superhero
oh okay so knock it off with the jail
time man this is a conversation amongst
men to cocaine's off the street
everybody's alive let's wrap this up
your well why we gonna pay the tax
welcome to pace and all weekend lower
you gonna hurt me I was like [ __ ]
Trump without the Trellick book
teleprompter I was [ __ ] practicing
and like down them like this what went
down your alley did no big deal walking
in there and he looked me up up and down
you'd like to address the speech he like
to address the court I like to two steps
forward and as I went to speak my voice
disappeared I say that like a little
[ __ ] mousy [ __ ] I was like you know I
just want you to know that and it just
broke and broke and broke like he was he
looking a little Fidel Castro
I've had he had a tiny little head but
it was all bad you look a baby gorilla
more you can see were lips and two
little white Italian eyes he told me to
step back like I had broken apart like I
just fell apart like I'm not ashamed to
say it
whatever speech whether they have been
doing on playgrounds and parks and delis
for 20 years he scared the [ __ ] out of
me like I broke it stand up 46 years
Department of Correction buddies were
there my girlfriend was there family was
no or you go to Rikers for that when I
was in Colorado oh you're in Colorado I
was stuck in college too Wednesday
Wednesday I was done two days later two
days later so we argued that fact unless
again which is a Heligan ounce ago
and about a half ounce of coke at the
house plus I had three buddies that have
flown out from New York they will hold
that and slept in three days they're in
court sweatin bullets trying to give
when we want to give a reference now
about the same Mike Duffy Tommy Russo
and some other guy sad potato showed up
on a [ __ ] Sunday morning they were at
the airport we came out the give you
support we'll be at the courtroom you
can hear him and the Rousseau guy at the
time was married to a 16 year old chick
he was married to when they check us
some [ __ ] and what and they showed up in
my courtroom like nothing and here's the
really ironic thing about life that I
shook all their hands I cried when I had
my girlfriend I felt really bad for a
family it couldn't make eye contact with
her family but when they led me in the
back cell like the first cell there was
a camera you know I had a suit on I took
the jacket off and I left a shirt with
the tie loosen my tie
I was overwhelmingly tired all this was
the stress of since 1979 I knew
that this day was gonna come what's my
mother once I put her in the ground I
knew this day was published it was 88
you said it was 88 it took nine years
mind you Wow I stayed out playing this
[ __ ] forget what to fold my jacket I
felt something in the jacket and I went
into the inside pocket and there was a
camera so I had to go buy this thank you
I mean this [ __ ] says what I love
about you not I didn't I wasn't gonna do
it I had to go by the sink because there
was the cat now I mean now how many
people could say that they snorted a
grandma blow in County Jail not too many
that's historic time I went over by the
same guy old break oh there it was I
started cash I started my wallet
something like belongs that they hadn't
processed me
I took the dollar bill I rolled it up I
did the whole [ __ ] thing in two blast
wow I was [ __ ] up 15 minutes I was joy
do you know next thing I know they were
waking me up waking you out why am i
because of the I was let's say you
Waylon the way the eighth of the weight
of the world was natural speed it was
nine years of [ __ ] hiding from people
robbing from people I was at peace
nobody could get to me the phone
couldn't ring nobody in this prison knew
me it was like I fell asleep but I
remember them waking me up and I was
really out of it like I was dying like
this had been ten years of me not
sleeping like not having peaceful sleep
calling asleep knowing that I gotta get
up tomorrow and [ __ ] go rob Siculus
house I gotta get up tomorrow figure out
how to get through burbank without
seeing Leigh Leigh's gonna go to all my
spots tomorrow try to football my game
up cuz I just Rob Lee leaves just
finding out right now he's missing a
kilo
so right now Lee's attacking all my spot
so it was like 9 years of that type of
stress just fell off my shoulders I
think he might have mentioned it before
but like why didn't he just like how
much of you thought about running when
your lawyer told you you were going to
jail like I don't know where another way
you go Mexico Americas both water had
just started and two years prior to that
I read an article about a guy that it
was 1980 and in 1951 he was on a party
and he was making out with some Czech
any bitter in the neck
what and he took a piece of meat either
I am and there was a salt and his
parents took the kid and got him out of
there and he moved into a new
residential area and he went to college
and an assumed name started a new life
and never again for 30 years they even
had police contact and then when they
got into a car accident he went to the
hospital they fingerprinted into the
background check of 9 he was wanted for
murder
oh he killed her when he killed her oh I
didn't realize I'm dying
oh yes yeah so I thought about that
story I thought about the story about
yeah I get away with it now what about
30 years from narang when I'm in [ __ ]
my kid I gotta go to a hospital god
forbid then they fingerprint me and
there I am cuz they usually do
background checks when you go to a
hospital ward a lot of people know that
this hotels that do background checks
when you call the airline as you're
speaking to them they're doing the
background check they actually even
flown them before yeah everything's
coming up so background checks were
moving that faster but I still remember
a story in Boulder about a guy way
before I got arrested way before I even
thought of getting arrested and he was
driving on a Saturday afternoon Sunday
Sunday afternoon God took car accident
his wife and baby died he ran from the
scene once they got him they realized
that he was a murderer from Florida that
was wanted for 20 years so I always knew
that the odds were against when you run
the odds will always be against that
if Vince is named Robert Durst [ __ ] and
if you run run for all you gotta
remember that once they get you know you
can't make bail cuz you're a flight risk
I don't want to be known as a flight
risk
you figure just get over once get over
with there was no running I had
committed I didn't go to prison for the
crime of kidnapping Vella yeah we
terrorized in that afternoon and tied
them up in the trunk of a car because to
this day I love come up behind I love
anybody who I did that you don't say him
but they all have to know that they were
also about if you do the time if you do
the crime you gotta do the time once you
put yourself into that world
that's insane there is a lifestyle there
is a lifestyle that comes it you not
distract you got to watch who you trust
you gotta watch who you talk to
there was a lot of if Italy comes to me
tomorrow and since I'm out of the five
can visit I'm getting into the cocaine
business I'm gonna give him a month I'm
a roblem just out of principle this I
know he doesn't know what he's doing I
don't for a fact he's a little bar one
of his Chucky [ __ ] be over there
eating an ice cream sundae with a kilo
in his refrigerator I'll send you over
there small nickel to hold them there
and I break into his house and take the
kilo you're gonna come in a retirement
just to get me no but I'm saying but you
know that was that's the mentality that
stuff you were gonna be that dumb I got
a rap you know if you're gonna be that
[ __ ] I know I can't tell you how many
people I know out here that grew we
visible you know 15 years ago had a
bunch of it in their place told
everybody and then people are outside
sitting on the place and one night they
come in [ __ ] five of them shotguns
masks they know where everybody is they
know what room everyone get get him out
of the video game room get you know boom
pull them all out made them all it was
it was four dudes I knew and one of them
sister made him all strip naked lay face
down on the kitchen floor and they took
everything
I mean TV they took everything and then
they rolled out and
if and you get up and call the police
we'll be back in five minutes there's
another car out there waiting to kill
you and they just lay there for a while
and then finally call but they got they
got hit twice cuz they talk too much
they tell everybody you know we got all
this we let me stop telling everybody
that you're telling her you're telling
everybody where you live these days
don't face but I'm out of town that's
another one y'all know you'd all be on
that [ __ ]
Lee's out of town for a week let's go to
his place and steal the [ __ ] coke
average what I leave town I got [ __ ]
cameras I got I got that sebastian
security system for then he talks about
Daisy I had the basic I went all out you
know what the [ __ ] neighbors are very
watchful on that block you know you have
to be I don't take anything for granted
because I know that's what I would
repeat what that most of all of us you
know when they were the most wrong with
what they were that's what I [ __ ]
take it down when you didn't even know
that when you get sloppy can't get
sloppy and what I made a living other
people getting too sloppy there was a
day where I put a suit on there was days
I just put a suit on and you see all
these buildings on like Bishop yeah I
would just walk up and down the
buildings and I'd knock on doors
he's right sick with here no there's no
Ryan Sickler here sorry but then you get
the white ass hold on let me check
yeah let me look in the log mind your
business do your work
it may come as I knocked on the door to
be a purse sitting on a [ __ ] you know
many times I knocked on the door open
then there'd be a deposit bag of it on
the desk and I'd look out in the hallway
nobody and I put the deposit bag take a
walk and there'd be two grand in that
tank you know I can't tell you how many
days I had this I had a happen five
times to it you just walk through the
building just walk through the building
like I owned it I didn't get a cent on
the job interview you want to die I
robbed the only kind of clock I'm
conscientious I'm there at night day
yeah I got the whole place open the safe
wide open safe was wide open
um I kept knocking hello Oh what do we
have here I walked out of then I took
the job I took I had a suit on I took so
much change
that's a seat with sideways I even took
the bag of nickels inside it's so
alright so back to you going into prison
you're you just snorted cocaine now are
they taking you on a bus right to the
penitentiary no that put it me in
Boulder County Jail you're going days
but a bus to the county jail no you're
right though that it's right for in
those days so boom you're in a Cell in
County Jail first are you with a solo
you and a bunch of people I'm a general
pop alright how many people would you
say isn't there 20 per unit and you say
here you are you scared I like to think
I'm a man I'd be scared to [ __ ] die
and even trying to [ __ ] I've but
whatever they told me to do I just curl
you know the word gets out I said are
you going in what are you in there for
kidnapping one and kidnap two with a
machine gun you're not gonna make
friends laughing thing also sounds like
it involves children that's the thing
that's gonna do it right it's about
moving a person's body one room toward
right yes against them would it help you
like I always my plan if I ever went to
president wants to hit a guard I'm just
going to solitary because I don't think
I'd survive him you might go to [ __ ]
hospital before you go to solitary in
solitary I've known me I either either
way but I just like the kidnapper with
machine gun make you seem like a badass
or no yes so when I walked in with the
kid ninh it was in the paper and the
whole thing and these people know when
you're coming in they know you're coming
in for you they start finding that no I
walked in with a [ __ ] Armani suit and
a white shirt on looking like Tom Jones
Midway yeah take the tie off yeah I got
sentenced at 9:30 in the morning I
didn't make it a cell till about 8
o'clock at night
damn that's a long fingerprint that you
both houses and the talking and what's
gonna happen and the paperwork I had a
sign it's about time I hit the cell was
like Monday night preseason football
like was on
I watched football for a while I made a
couple collect calls let people know you
know I was my girlfriend doing that
while they were going through it and
then the next day is when you go see
like the counselor and he told me that
you got sentenced to this this is what's
about to happen would you they start
talking everything you're eligible for
and then the guy said listen you might
be in luck because the prisoners are so
backed up that you're not gonna see
diagnostic till December or January
what's that diagnostic is where you have
to go first so they do testing on you
and determine what prison you gonna be
sent it they give you a class or I'll
grade and it determines what prison
you're going to be sent it so I sat in
can I go so how old I'm in County Jail
for and they go December January and
that's good because it's two for one
Sangha in two days for the price of one
and she goes but you might get
transferred did I go women on your
transients and she goes we just signed a
deal with half the inmates are gonna go
to Missouri and you know they're gonna
taxes and I go can't sign me the either
those I don't know have any family that
like well you should have thought about
that before you kidnapped a [ __ ]
great day the night before like the next
day the next night they were like these
next people pack up your bundles you're
leaving in the morning
ba-ba-ba-ba-ba I'm like [ __ ] where are
we going none of your [ __ ] business
called asleep in vicked
you know they're you don't know nothing
and you got a visit tomorrow morning you
just got off the phone with your
girlfriend she's bringing you you're
close to them and your books and [ __ ]
you just cut a deal to [ __ ] and
coming to and next thing you know
they're waking you up at 6:00 and they
took me to something Summit County Jail
which is like going from the YMCA and
North Hollywood to the YMCA in Hollywood
another why I'm saying the Hollywood now
looks like [ __ ]
what the Jim look like it [ __ ] arsh
wits that thing over there they got the
pool with no towel like they definitely
do something bad thing over there you
ever gonna report go no home it's like
Lucille Ball was in there in that shower
and stuff nice people great place but
it's [ __ ] wash with so today the
weightlifting the whole [ __ ] thing go
to the Hollywood why Sandra Bullock
donates two million a year to the sauna
and jacuzzi when you go on the hollywood
wide sauna when you come out the jacuzzi
the bubbles your skin feels like [ __ ]
glass it's nice how it's beautiful the
comedy fact i got a sauna they got a
heated pool shower with ducks
i went to sell a county jail you can
wear your clothes
hang on the sun all day that didn't
bother you and that ten o'clock the jail
or what this supermarket for you come on
you went to the A&P for you am pay I
haven't heard that you buy pay him
whatever 20 bucks and he get your chips
cold cuts a sandwich a gallon of milk
cheerios whatever you want it so every
night around nine we give him money he
come back around 10:00 you gave him your
nightly [ __ ] I think one of the guys got
the guards to get a booze for Halloween
does Luke know I'm lying to you guys
then I never even made Halloween I got
there I got to that place like August
19th they told me I wouldn't make
diagnostic so January my attorney was so
good I made diagnostic my August 24th
okay so when I was up in Summit County
they came to me and said you packing up
and leaving the mom warning goddamnit
where am I going now
whole day in the morning that more than
they took us a diagnostic that's like a
four-hour [ __ ] bus ride the king and
said he need nothing to eat shackle next
to people well they had a good time to
sell Academy Jam it sounds like it's
like it I met this very interesting dude
at that place I've never haven't
forgotten that told me uh didn't tell me
I read his
police reports and it was very what he
did he got caught for drugs by the feds
on the Fed eight kilos of coke Jesus and
he cut the deal to get the eight kilos
back and take eight kilos that he had to
cut a big a deal and the feds could take
everybody in so tell me he's getting his
eight back and this is cut a deal he
made this is why I always tell you
anything is possible he got arrested
like right now I'm selling you eight
kilos you're undercover bull undercover
they took him back to a police station
he goes hold on one second
why are we doing this I know a place
that's got we could sell to the guy and
get his connection to come up and he
told him some story in the feds board
like imma get you to big fish right so
he picked up a phone he called the
federal and a Dale the next day he was
to get his eight kilos back go to his
house get the other 16 pounds he had
bundle it and take it to a house and
drop it off and the cops are gonna swarm
that house okay
the cops surrounded the house the guy
did exactly what he thought was told to
do pull up walk into the house the cops
outside waited five minutes ten minutes
15 minutes 20 minutes our friend already
had a little car parked around the
corner arranged he got the car one of
his buddies 16 kilos and then planted
the six years sexier they caught him
they extradite him and they brought him
back to Colorado well he was we play
handball all day my suntan you should
have seen my god when I was a southern
County Jail I look like a [ __ ] movie
star you understand me I look like
Ricardo Montalban no SPF nothing I just
stay up there all day playing [ __ ]
handball I'm saying something you kind
of want to go back
Oh keep it up I'm with stab you go buddy
I swear to god it was one of the best
[ __ ] 60s ice it sounds like it for
real they're going off control call you
would walk into the [ __ ] receptionist
office and call those Colorado jails
like [ __ ] jokes where Bundy escape
from Aspen County Jail all those jobs
where he escaped yeah he said he was
gonna make a call and jumped out a
window the last time I checked the maybe
three that Aspen County Jail didn't have
its cafeteria so they got it all their
meals catered so they would get
breakfast time at the time from Paula
France they get like a bayonet my finger
like a [ __ ] of croissants with egg
whites Rock Lee and a croissant was
tremendous everybody knew if you're not
gonna rested go to [ __ ] yeah
then they took me to a place diagnostic
and that was what you see in the movies
that's what it was called diagnostic and
penance a penitentiary it's connected to
a three or four different prisons holy
[ __ ] but they put you two there for 14
days to determine you physically
mentally psychologically to worry that
they run you through a gamut of tests
and then once you're there you determine
where they don't know all right you're
now going here so where do they send you
from there so I had three options I had
rifle give you options yeah I don't know
you I didn't have no options I had out
my options the options were right the
yeah okay so you wait a person when you
go to prison on different things did he
have a job at the time of his arrest
first time offender did he have a job
did he have a high school diploma was he
attending school so I had my attorney
and made me cover all these things so
when I went my point was my points would
be off so when those days the court had
a sit the court system had a thing that
if a point system that's a location you
had to be at so if you between 0 & 2
you belong to the halfway
do you know what I was minus 1.5 ah
where do you belong that met my
eligibility meant that I should just go
diagnosed and turn around into a
community correction facility but
Community Corrections had turned me down
because of the weapon I see so dad if
that's my real story because I got the
GED I was working at the time my arrest
it was basically my first arrest yeah we
made a call and got rid of all the
arrest records in New Jersey that's one
call away their friends know exactly how
to pull hard everything was clear in
Jersey there was no violence in my
police record so my attorneys also
turned a kidnapping into a nine violent
crime that was his point from the
beginning News
you gonna get in trouble you're gonna
get it but let's dial it back but I'm
gonna dial it back I'm gonna hire a
public investigator
I'm gonna take your testing I'm with not
at that time I had only one act of
violence
I'd hit a guy in the head with a bud
wire with a Heineken bottle on the 80th
Street and Kennedy Boulevard three days
after he graduated high school I didn't
graduate but it was like three days
after graduation all of us will [ __ ]
jizz dump and one Sunday night were out
hanging out and the car makes a u-turn
and you know with a little tough time
Templeton one of the boulevard this guy
wants to be Joe muscles and he said
something we was four of us he said
something and he came out of the car
with an axe handle with no accent and as
he was walking towards us I had a
Heineken I [ __ ] just tipped it over
I'm doing it and this he got a tree from
me I just went into a Roger Clemens wine
doesn't and it busted just had bloodshot
it [ __ ] tomato and you thought
[ __ ] Mickey Mantle and hit a home run
the drive the [ __ ] turned white and the
kid
stumbled around with blood he just got
another [ __ ] convertible whatever
they had and sped off I never heard
nothing about
we live at cops knocked on my door and
he showed up in : having a banach or my
stepdad [ __ ] hysterical you know and
I had were being the court my friend
Louie cast Alito's mother was the court
clerk you know how was the meatballs
Lundy Alvia it was [ __ ] hysterical
but I'll never forget the case before me
was a guy named Freddie Rupp Freddie
rubber Simone this is the what before
you the case before me you can remember
the [ __ ] Randy was name it was one of
the funniest
I knew Fred erupt from the neighbor how
you knew Freddie Freddie rough listen
told the guy that was just in and out of
jail that was just he would really kill
you he was really a character and he was
three or four days away from killing
somebody
this is his 20th time the front of his
judge and he liked me eight years later
the cocaine had convinced him that he's
the [ __ ] the dog [ __ ] out of this is one
of my first times ever in court without
my parent it's like when I was a kid I
loved his go to quarrel with my mom for
bookmaking but this is one of the first
times they told me sit and watch and
I'll never forget when mrs. cast Widow
looked up and you know mrs. cast leader
just came to see me at the West Palm
Beach I'm probably you serious with her
son Louie they just moved back to New
Jersey Louie was my boom ba groaning up
and he should be mad at me woman
we went to see Apocalypse Now one night
when I first came out we all do they
have acid and me and my two friends well
I listened tell Louie we can't hear
nothing and there was a siren going off
and Louise like the hey that sounded
like we don't hear nothing you did there
for about 10 minutes
he's been thought it was a problem so I
get the coin as long as I live and I
will call Timmy ha when we write that
back up my story was the whole town
heard about it oh this is 1982 I think
when war with Beirut
we have water I'm checking your war with
somebody and then go okay next up who's
on the agenda and the court clerk says
mr. Frederick Frederick grew up and the
judge goes oh this is gonna be an
interesting morning I mean I knew this
guy everybody knew his [ __ ] Freddy walks
in there with shackles on and [ __ ] you
know the orange jumpsuit and they're
like mr. rubb you're being charged like
you know aggravated because he didn't do
nothing bad it wasn't it was like a
misdemeanor but he was on on bail for
something else at the time and this is
like a normal occurrence then he's like
yeah you know bond awesome the judge
goes home mr. up what do you have to say
any goes lesson your honor we're gonna
end this [ __ ] right now
for the ladies watch your language here
they call it oh [ __ ] that [ __ ] that
there's a war going on in Beirut yeah
Lebanon in he goes there's a war going
on in Beirut and you have me sitting
here with a jumpsuit on you're on it how
dare you and everybody the court was
like what is he saying he goes let me
out of here right now and step up we're
gonna play in the Beirut I'll go over
there kill so many [ __ ] I'll
make you proud of killing people I want
to kill people and the whole courts
Howard like will [ __ ] just Highland
cuz it's Freddie r up at the Kai's Lee
listen if he wants to join the army let
him go
just take them downstairs change them
make sure you drop more of a through
thanks everybody
yeah I think Freddie beat the cop up on
the way the recruiter no more soldier
[Laughter]
suddenly bring my case up immediate and
the guy everybody had to dummy up like
the ambulance guy didn't show the
hospital worth of the emergency room
died didn't show the cop that was called
from Union City to report the crime
enough bragging didn't show so they were
gonna give us 24-hour reprieve the kids
standing there all stitched up you know
I'm like I don't know what he's talking
about and they were talking about a
civil suit I would seen that kid again
never heard my boy and his name was
nothing that was my [ __ ] home what
the joy 3 weeks--i going in and out of
court I figure out whether I was guilty
that's more exciting than any of our
whole lives and his crazy [ __ ] I told
this story on Rogan but I had a cousin I
have a cousin he's my father's first
cousin
he's a now paranoid schizophrenic he was
not to begin with he was a smart kid did
well in school was great at sports was
really good at lacrosse Hopkins was
looking at him he had lots of offers
Syracuse I think his black belt in
karate second or third degree but
started [ __ ] around with drugs young
and by his I don't know maybe two
thirties he was gone and I'm still very
close with all his kids they're my
cousins obviously and we toss they'll
talk to my cousin actually the cousin I
told you got carjacked though this is
one of his kids so he is sometimes
allowed into halfway houses and then
other times he has got to be in a mental
home on medication so once they get the
medication right he gets into his own
little it's a Baltimore City you know I
don't know quad or whatever you know
he's got his own place but there's
several other ones in there you know and
it's dirty and and he's got a ashtray at
just 100 cigarettes and he'll smoke the
butts and he's got writing all on the
walls Scripture and
hey I just was fascinated by my father
that he was our say no to drugs built-in
say no to drugs in the [ __ ] house you
know what I mean like you can end up
like that I was always scared of drugs
because I didn't none of us wanted to be
that and I would say to him like what
are these poems and stuff on the wall
and he was like my doctors at night my
doctors come in through my window they
drop liquid acid in my ear and then they
sample my skin and then they leave and
then after they leave the love of my
life comes in and I'm incapacitated so
this [ __ ] on the walls are the things
that I want to tell her and it's a
paragraph here a poem here this here
that here and I should go over his house
and we would always take a plate of food
for Christmas I would be his through his
three kids me and my two brothers all
six of us roll over and then we give him
a joint we'd smoke with him a little bit
and this [ __ ] were always before
we could drive back one mile to my Aunt
Margarite's house with her hair of my
grandmother this [ __ ] already
called and said hey thanks for the
dinner they came over smoke me out got
me some so we're walked back into that
ambush and we're and we would always
play like you and listen this
[ __ ] crazy listen to him but
then we would call him I'm like we're
never [ __ ] smoking you out again you
[ __ ] piece of [ __ ] and he would just
be laughing his ass off
so I go over one day and I sit down with
him he's watches television with the TV
volume off and a radio on and after a
while that [ __ ] synced up and I said man
this shit's starting to get real [ __ ]
weird here I miss mates when it made
sense when his world made sense to me I
got real uncomfortable and I was like
I'm getting the [ __ ] out of here so I
leave and not too long after this he
goes and gets his hair cut up on the on
the Avenue Eastern Avenue was like the
Ventura Boulevard of Baltimore he goes
up and and this woman now and this is a
guy that's not mentally stable
this woman's touching his head and
cutting his hair so in his mind
she must she must love me she must love
me so he goes home and gets his guitar
now he's always selling it she sells his
bed his guitar anything to get
cigarettes drug
lottery tickets whatever gets a check
from the government can't [ __ ] work
it's a small check gets his guitar and
the the crazy beautiful thing about it
is every time he has that [ __ ]
guitar it's always out of tune but it's
always out of tune the same exact way
every guitar he gets he Tunes it a
certain way and it's always out of two
minutes the scene so he walks up to the
shop he stands out in front of the hair
salon and he sees the girl in there her
name's Carissa
but people Baltimore have a weird accent
and he says Chrissa that's how he says
so he stands out in front of the store
and the glass one and he says Chrissa
and she looks out so he starts playing
his song he's gone Chris I love you
Chris I need you and then he starts
hitting Krystal don't cry because I want
to die Krystal Oh fry because I want to
die it she's like what the [ __ ] she
calls the police they arrest them they
quickly they know who he is he's been
arrested a ton of times they know he's
not well they released him for his
halfway house but the court dates coming
up and at the time I'm homeless my
grandmother's just died I'm living with
her sister my aunt Marguerite she takes
me in and she's raising her grandkids
all my cousins are there and it's court
date and we're like we gotta go [ __ ]
watch this and worse we go to the wrong
[ __ ] courthouse and we panic so we
could shoot across North Baltimore now
we make it just in time he's in there
with my aunt his mom and it's a late a
female judge and he he said she hears
what Carissa has to say first you know
and she gets it she knows what's going
on but she's being super sweet to my
cousin and she's like sir you know what
would you like to say he's like I just
don't understand what I did wrong
this lady was nice to me I went home I
wrote her a song and I came up to
perform it you know and and she's like I
I know what's going on here you know she
gets it she's looking at the papers he's
so she goes he's like can I just sing a
couple of the lines of the song she said
yeah if you'd like to this fella like
we're all like each other watching each
other you gotta be [ __ ] kid
right now and he hits it with Chris I
love you Chris I need you snow guitar
ready he's just going Chris little cry
because I want to die
Kristen I'll cry at the judge Lee okay
all right all right we know I know
what's going on here so she's about to
release him back to health care you know
halfway house order and she goes oh I'm
sorry there's an outstanding warrant for
your arrest on your record here and he
just shoots back and looks at you know
his mom and he's like what is it she
says says every cook that's my uncle
head and he did not like on the lid so
when he heard every cook he was like oh
this [ __ ] what happened was he
he took a cab to her house one night all
[ __ ] up and they wouldn't pay for it
so he took a brick and threw it through
there you know [ __ ] storm door window
and [ __ ] all over the place they called
the cops
they dropped the charges they really did
drop the charges but it's a clerical
error it never got taken off the Rick
she said well I'm sorry if that's the
case but for now we have to take you
under arrest and now he's [ __ ] going
nuts there shackling him up but he's
like what that she's screaming baggies
like [ __ ] these [ __ ] this
[ __ ]
and my aunt stands up and everybody in
Baltimore calls everybody honey okay
and my aunt stands up and says to this
judge hon we dropped those charges and
that judge said you will not call me
hard but we were nigh this whole things
falling apart she said you will address
me as your honor said I'm sorry your
honor we dropped those charges she's
like well we're gonna have to get that
cleared up and in the meantime he's
gonna be spending the night in in jail
and it took him out yelling all the way
up shut door that was the idea there as
well when you say he did drugs they got
[ __ ] was their mental health issue first
and your drugs fueled it that well I
believe there was nothing anybody really
saw but I think he was one of those
people that like Syd Barrett from Pink
Floyd you know did so much asset
unlocked it and turned him so he told
he's told me himself I've done every
drug you could think of he was big on
acid and that's what [ __ ] had turned
him it shifted into another person
was my drug of choice acid yeah for two
or three years - how often were you
doing it every day hey how many times a
died my mother died November 79 I did
acid Li I started doing acid before she
died but afterward it was the only way I
could clear out my head I felt like at
night that's powerful laughter clear
that out that's a different acid this is
you know the acid that we have now I've
done it a few times
it's good for three hours yeah you tell
me you have it over the doorsill back
y'all yeah we have liquid think I don't
have gotten that acid the 12-hour the
eight hours of intense shits melting you
have to be with people yeah really like
see what's going on but then that gets
to a point where you're by yourself
well you have that long talk with
yourself wife whatnot I did a lot of
that [ __ ] that kept me from jumping off
a bridge so it's weird that any day now
there's always days I tell people I
can't wait to walk into a restaurant one
day [ __ ] my aunt wrote on the wall
expecting that's more the acid I did
well you stopped he never stopped he
continued to do it even when he got
crazy I mean there were times where I
would take him so he would love to go to
the hospital that's one of the things he
really liked to do and he he would tell
me all the time that he's like Ryan I
had he would tell me see this funny
thing was when he was on his meds you
could tell he was there and that's when
he would start telling the family
secrets and I and they would be like oh
shut don't listen him I've known oh hold
on hold on you just keep talking over
here you keep talking you know he when
he's not there he's over here with the
eyes - head tilt and drifting away but
when he's there he'll tell you the
secrets so I was always good to him no
he's my he's my dad's first cousin my
dad would bring him out to the house and
always try to help
you know he would come to my granny
would take a cab to my grandmother's
he'd sit in a chair across from me like
you he would smoke cigarettes he smokes
a carton in three days and he doesn't
take him any farther than right here
he's hitting him like that mikemaya
Marguerite's dead of cancer this
[ __ ] is smoking three a carton
in three days and he's not doesn't have
throat cancer or anything still alive
still alive now and I take him to the
hospital one time and he's screaming
he's telling me that the nurses come in
and [ __ ] him every now and then and he's
Tom he's gotten this STD and I'm like
what he's what what do you have what
what are you seeing that you think you
got an STD he's like I got this scab
right here on my stomach and I was like
that's not a [ __ ] STD man it's a scab
I'm looking at the scab on your stomach
he's like I'll take care of that he goes
in there and he starts screaming and in
the waiting room and I'm just like Jesus
Christ and he gets on there's a Gurney's
he gets on it he's demanding to be seen
he goes back he comes back out and he's
he's had that cigarette raspy laugh and
he would get laughing and it would start
making me laugh like what the [ __ ] they
say they told me it was I go what
because what my STD I go yeah he goes I
pick the scab I threw it away I go
that's not how that [ __ ] works dude but
that's what he believes and it's funny
that the kids I did that acid with I
still communicate from that time that
jump
I'm Eminem turned seven days to the 80s
one of the met issues a couple years ago
but he had inheritance issues he had a
dad that was always you know he had an
aunt that was in the back closet like
you go over in here yeah yeah
I probably grew up around three families
that had a son being the house that live
there wit so if I narrow it down the two
dear dear friends I have to burn right
now with his sister one desist had
mental fissures and the other one at
stant
the one at the end just and then wow
he's still alive and he's still doing
Wow but just a couple things suicide how
does this affect you guys I mean I enjoy
you've talked about you dealing with
almost people but around here let me see
like what little homeless people yelling
and screaming people right now there's
two people were dealing with the guy
that had the aunt he's had a lot of
problems and the guy that had the sister
was dear friends with me and he snapped
15 years he did not least snapped his
personality what a different way he
released our hometown as his hometown
doesn't return calls doesn't talk to
people from our group you know it's
hurtful today was his older brother's
birthday after the older brother but
I've asked the older brother how's your
brother doing oh one of the few guys in
this life that when I spoke to him he
said that he did appreciate why they
called my we have a good time growing up
had the two people have said that yeah
we were - this is back in 2002 when I
was getting ready to shoot analyze this
mm-hmm I had the last time I had seen
him was like 93 I had a coke party in
fact me and him jumped in the car eight
times a pitch see each other but he had
a gambling problem and he blamed us for
his gambling problem later on in life so
he caught us all off so it was weird and
I feel bad because I know when I talked
to his brother that
this guy has made it all through life
but those mental health issues have been
working because he doesn't he leaves his
house on it leaves work on Friday and he
stays in his house until Sunday and come
out no shopping no restaurants no movies
no malls no nothing it's so bad that his
wife picks up and leaves and goes to her
family's house
it just gives him the place and just
gives him the bucket because he just
can't be around people yeah like that so
it's always I've always thought like
I've always been scared for myself if
I'm not feeling right or whatever I
always write you know if it's a couple
days then we have a problem
I started broken down to see a
psychiatrist I don't hear words ever no
no really
yeah I don't want to I don't want I
don't like the scabs I want to open it's
because I want to open them on my terms
no because you want to open it Dean I'm
saying yeah and I think that sometimes
with psychiatrists they make problems
where there's not we already have this
problem yeah let's deal with this but
you want to open up this to deal with
this no now I'm really [ __ ] up for
three weeks so it's like I mental I've
handled my own mental health and I've
handled it with a notebook I've handled
and a microphone the notebook is more
the notebook has been more mentally in
the mental health because I look back to
where my frame of mind was those
previous years I look back to you know I
would love to I think I'm gonna do a
whole podcast of excerpts of my writings
the last two years
oh yeah before I was doing coke you
gotta read somebody before you start
stopped I've stopped all the last two
years of your coke your coke years I got
those albums you know it's not just
jokes you're writing you were right your
journaling oh okay that's different than
I said so I get home I when I wake up in
the morning I journal my day what my
plans are
that's really good in health you have
the journal more that's what cleans up
the mental diarrhea you got your mind
all night that's when you smoke in
YouTube music on the windows are open
get the Sun it's getting air in that's
that whole process I do the morning
journal then I do the 8 o'clock during
the day turned out how I wanted to I'm
headed down to the store I feel sorry
for the [ __ ] who's gotta follow
me tonight cuz I'm ready to get my dick
sucked tonight you know I prepare myself
and then when I get home I have the
wrap-up Journal the store was great
tonight I hate a bag of dicks it's so
bad I'm gonna take a week off
you don't say any way out so you're
always in touch with yourself mentally
Jay Larson gave me this book and I can't
remember it now but it's the same thing
it's you you what you're gonna do for
the day come home what you did and at
night that's it what you could have done
better not so you did wrong that's how
you could have improved that a lot do
this boom this [ __ ] he's never
getting a call from me again right I had
called him twice he never called my
could suck my [ __ ] dick
but did at the end of the day as always
I tried for it to be I wanted to be
ultra positive because I want to go to
bed ultra positive so I could wake up
ultra policy if not if I write about
Ryan Sickler doing a racist joke that
was very offensive they're gonna wake up
at 2:00 and be mad at Ryan thinking
about that [ __ ] sure I read it write
it out now get that writing and it's
writing it's the muscle that needs to be
written every day this is how you start
genius yes place I won't learn how to
write a script write the script do your
life first then come see me that's the
hardest script he's on the right dose
start from the beginning I was born in
Boston hospital 1952 on a hot summer
night bill syat and Pina McGurk and
that's it that's how it starts that's
what you write that's the first homework
assignment having
Doug Stanhope that's all you need that's
your first script strike villain you
can't write the story your wife it's not
gonna work out for you and I did it I
just don't know where that notebook is
it was horrible spelling was wrong wrong
pronunciation commas everywhere 22
there's but it I did the assignment it
took me a year to write and I threw the
notebook away when I was finished with
it just because I didn't know better but
I feel that the paper and pen are the
strongest weapon psychiatrist there is
if you're honest enough to write what's
really cooking with you that's right
yeah that's how that's good and healthy
for you straight man what do you think
about the homeless situation you know we
all know the homeless situation they're
[ __ ] [ __ ] but you know if they
did a survey and went around with little
dip kits and [ __ ]
and you could tell 70% of these people
whacked up that live under the bridges
they're not people who could get an
apartment tomorrow they're not two weeks
from getting on a [ __ ] apartment
doesn't take you Jim check out the
corner building a three-ring circus the
170s got an exercise bicycle over there
the guys are savage you got an exercise
spotlight now who the [ __ ] walks around
the neighborhood sees an exercise bike
before it says I need my yeah but I went
to Philadelphia Atlantic City last week
I mean guess what
I took my full run to the train station
manic city but I dropped them off for
5:00 in the morning
there was not one homeless [ __ ]
really they had four police guys
standing there go chase him out and h8
that's these coke they don't feel bad
for homeless people I kick it
they kick it I would say I'm ugly guy in
the number one bus how old were you we
had about 13 13 how old's the guy he had
to be about 34 he got on the bus and he
fell asleep from being drunk
this is nighttime yeah it was like seven
o'clock at night he was all [ __ ] up so
I
my buddy sat next one put his arm around
in the [ __ ] and then he's like he's
coming with us let's take a look whom we
just carry them out like you took him
out we're gonna bills of Bernie he's
leaving the bus drivers like we think of
Spanish he's a friend of mine he lives
down the corner soon as the bus took off
we just dropped him kicked them and took
his wall he has a four hours of [ __ ]
get well wonder why they put me in jail
okay well well done so back to this
alright you're going to [ __ ] what's
it called again diagnostic I want to do
diagnostic it's a two-week process when
draw blood they do when you finally get
assigned to the penitentiary you're
going to day one there okay I wanted to
go to rifle well you said there were
three offices three-hour rifle at that
time there was rifle camp joins West by
golden well they make beep drug boys oh
really
yeah and then there was another one at
the time under the side of the slope
that was when you worked at farms and
pigeons and I was not going to that one
it was a bunker type you slept
underneath I heard it was really cold
year-round yeah that'll my attorney we
wrote some type of what about allergies
and whatever was just the narrow it down
out of that one between Camp George
Austin rifle and I wanted to go to rifle
because they had a swimming program in
the prison to the prison that was from
program it was minimum security for that
a swimming program plus in the summer
you were a lifeguard at the local pool
they would send you out there to be you
were a lifeguard at the Llano and then
the wintertime you could be a cedar guy
at the movie theater that a big so it's
a work-release that he'll normally
release just was trying to get you back
and it wasn't work release but this
prison if you did exceptional they got
you uh whatever you call them at a movie
theater they make
for you with Usher yeah you could work
as an assassin will we do that that was
[ __ ] great hell yeah
but it was also a five hour drive from
Denver you had to go for one way so my
girlfriend would have to go five and
then five that's how it was a rifle I
had letters to the the [ __ ] guy from
rifles saying I really want to go there
would be a great addition to the movie
grated applause and all this [ __ ] in
that morning when I woke up and they
said Camp George West it's like me
telling you we're gonna send you to
prison but you're gonna go to Burbank
do you like should I be happy about that
right yeah I had my heart set on San
Diego you know so they put me in camp
George West which was in Burma golden
which was 20 minutes from Burbank and
the final with no traffic mold over 30
minutes from mold or some way that would
no traffic
very enjoyable so dick really yeah
so I grew up in Maryland where I grew up
in the county there's a mental
institution called Springfield and it's
laid out like a college campus and at
the end of this campus here there was a
minimum security prison we called it the
laundry camp because that's what we were
that's what they all told us they did
there they did laundry for like the
state and all the clothes and all that
where any of that so did you deal with
any of that kind of [ __ ] there no but
you know what I'm talking that you
worked in the kitchen
the our possibilities of my camp was
great because you either did laundry
worked in the kitchen did the crew you
ever see those guys with sticks on road
Route five picking up garbage oh yeah
yeah you do that or you've got to be the
guy that drove the van and they put the
garbage on the van okay okay so you
probably got to be well-behaved to do
the very overhand or be able to have a
driver's license how many think those
mutts have drivers and bonuses so that
those commendable correction camps are a
lot of the last stop before you get to a
halfway house can those guys have done
20 years they don't have a [ __ ]
tracks
but they're almost on their way back
outside they have to do two or three is
a minimum halfway on then the stakes
right then they go up in front of the
parole board but if the parole board
either paroles amount or they get
paroled to a halfway house okay so with
meaning right around the corner from our
middles White House right altogether
altogether yeah so when they when I went
in there when I got there no get your
bags go see a counselor and you see the
counselor then he'll tell you what
options you have you have a few days to
fill applications up not applications
like sign your name and before I could
walk out some big [ __ ] black dude six
foot six music excuse me mr. dye is have
you ever had hepatitis B I'm like do I
look like a hepatitis B or whatever he
asked me about some disease like oh no
he was good I see you at 5:00 a.m. use a
baker oh okay so he took me in the
kitchen to make me a bacon I almost blew
up the kitchen I didn't know how to bake
a slim program [ __ ] cinnamon
roll dough but there was no slim program
on that right gotcha I want the cam
George Wes the the Lou of cam George
Weiss was that you got to leave once a
day every day for 20 minutes off-campus
audible data point six miles from the
fair
so it was basically a five-minute walk
so that would give you 15 minutes in
that mode day gonna buy a notebook ice
cream cheese whatever Lee was punished
Lee would give me money which I took $1
off the top court for taking the walk
that you follow me yeah so every day you
signed up a lot of people didn't have
that privilege I had that took me a week
to get that privilege once I almost blew
up the kitchen they made me the stock
clerk which was the easiest job there
was a stock clerk / dishwasher so yeah
Spock in the morning dishes to three
sets a dish
the dentist and I'd be done but the guy
with the license got fired got caught
doing heroin ah so he lost his job they
wasn't through the database I had a
license I got the motor as a dishwasher
so I became the stock clerk and then I
would go out and pick up the garbage
I've drive out here they know I wouldn't
pick up the gun I'm lying here
they made me bring the lunch sandwich
okay to the site but you go pick him up
you actually got out yes but these guys
were geniuses they would never tell you
where you were gonna go work - the day
before there was no cell phones and does
this so they would I created a system
that when I went to bring them lunch
they would slip me a phone number
cost you a couple dollars and I would go
back cual that number and tell Ryan
Sickler was and then they would go over
there and one of Ryan's causes at draw a
balloon filled with heroin and I get a
little taste of that thing I was like
cuz that's what I did yeah they piss
testing at all back then if they had a
suspicion right then the car but they
couldn't find the acid speed and some
mouse okay so the big flavors of the
Halloween and covert are new meth speed
and the acid okay
that's that method type speed and acid
were the only things they couldn't read
they had to do a tap into your spine to
do the acid and they weren't gonna spend
$20 to see you could ask $2,000 so the
drugs of choice in there were blood acid
and speed for the guys I ran with there
was a whole different culture in that I
was doing heroin full time in there it's
crazy to see that it that's a really
crazy culture yeah so I would go back
there was a certain guy that would give
me five bucks I call him tell Lucy meet
him on the exit of this and this and
we'll never get back they would eat
dinner and then they were disappearing
and
it'd be like [ __ ] and walking dead
they would get high enough so nobody
would know and they would sell the
cotton balls because you put your
syringe in the cotton ball to draw those
cotton balls to have heroin and then
they would sell the copper minute was on
it was such a weird culture a witness
when I was in there like what they did
to get high by even behind bars like
even being in jail didn't really teach
you right when I got locked up I knew
that I had to give coke a break anyway
so I stepped away from the coke stepped
away from the weed as much as I wanted
to weed was my [ __ ] life but I knew
they would test me and find me you don't
and they wouldn't get me for was the
acid which I ended up popping lucky a
few times then on Monday that was just
named John Clark it's so weird how the
movies show you all these prison gangs
but as well I'm thinking sitting here
thinking because you talked about
swimming at one and and driving a van
and when when I went to the one where I
grew up my buddy would play in this
softball league and the prisoners had a
team they were all it was always a home
game though they were off hey they never
allowed to travel and it was a laundry
camp so they were called themselves the
dirty socks right and ain't my buddies
like you got to come and watch one of
these right I'm telling you it'll be a
fence right here well you know all the
families and kids will sit on the gate
and then it's all the prisoners over
here so I go watch one one day it's the
best [ __ ] thing I've ever seen in my
life
I'm sitting on a grass Hill and there's
a guy up in the booth he's got a little
Casio keyboard I don't see him till the
end of the whole thing but he's the
announcer he's the you know keyboard guy
so they would get up to bat the
prisoners and he be like alright y'all
now batting number number two Jeffrey
Rosen y'all know him as Oreo and the
bleachers would it go crazy and then he
will pop out and they'd be like [ __ ] you
up you know they would turn on him like
a [ __ ] they had so many fun and
then he had these little son songs he
would play and one was always a beat off
you go deed to the odd to the
all to the T to the Y dirty socks in the
house come on y'all and all the
prisoners like dude
they had cheers they had everything
going and then if they made an out he
plays a little remember the Casio
keyboard we could sample sounds yeah
that's what he had out there and he
would do shoot him down dirty socks he
would do that one all the time he had
all kinds of little sayings up there all
the time and when he got done I'll never
forget I waited I wanted to see who this
dude was this dude was a tiny little
skinny black who had that long ass
keyboard tucked on his arm and remember
those skull caps but they had to Panama
Jack flaps down absolutely walk back up
the hill to the prison I guess that was
his job that was what he got to do and
he enjoyed the [ __ ] out of it I'm
telling you man I know they were
prisoners of ship without dam I had my
buddy hit a home run they're all talking
[ __ ] to him and then they would go he
would go what any charge it was always
off Keegan he would do that and then he
go where cellblock B right and there the
guy's little sections dude it was the
best I was like is this [ __ ] real man
we got to put this in a goddamn movie
it's the best [ __ ] I've ever seen I did
you have that salt ball or any that [ __ ]
there we did everything we had a
softball league like dorms in between
them we play the [ __ ] the the guards
it's so funny what real prison we had a
basketball league on Monday nights a
bunch of us would do speed and go play
basketball like a line of speed and
getaway basketball I but would they
allow the out like the aerial - nothing
like that no we were really secluded
that one was I hold that whole eight
experience was so close okay so that
close gonna ask you so you got about a
year in out of they were gonna give you
four or four but what happened was
Colorado had just instituted alcohol
House bill 1228 and it was your first
offense your sentence wouldn't get
caught now so
I had a 48 month sentence so
automatically my seconds got cut to 24
months and you were getting back double
days for one back then right hold on
I had dirty days at two days a piece so
that put me down to twenty two days and
you're in you're eligible for a halfway
house at 18 months
see you got formal and there was
something else that they took a month
off for so basically when I had sentence
I had twenty months and in two months
they were gonna put me in my paperwork
had done would be was done for a halfway
house now if I stayed in County for six
months I would still have to go through
diagnostic and then they would have
transferred me to a halfway house
because after they put the letter in it
takes six weeks stay weeks to get
transferred and you have to remember you
put down you get an option to mark down
two boxes they could send you anywhere
right they could send you to [ __ ]
Santa Hannah and you know wait but my
mother lives in North Hollywood there's
one in there that it's [ __ ] you and your
mother all right so your eternity really
has to start getting into the process
now I asked George Perez this question I
might ask you this question but you get
water trying it one of those two please
[Music]
thank you I like smoking my marijuana
before you ask this question that that I
think you do silence I love smoking my
own marijuana I love doing my elbows but
if I had a [ __ ] biker today I would
pop - that's how much pain I'm in right
now I lifted on Monday man with the
boxing class yesterday 12 stations times
three but with Apple yesterday I was I
hate a bunch of bulls at the store
during those [ __ ] games those shows
last [ __ ] sugar than that thing is
that some guy game I hate a capful so
when you eat that it dehydrates it while
you sleep so I woke up to a super
[ __ ] soul I guess an ad I have two
cups of coffee one regular and one
[ __ ] expresso but seriously right now
when I went to get up I'm like oh my god
I am so [ __ ] physically so so sorry
to interrupt you now watch is there any
part of you that misses it in any way I
know you're a family man you've got
chili chili chili Rijn I know you're
married but is there any part like what
George's answer was yes he missed the
structure he missed knowing that any day
I can go to the library I can go here I
can go here where when you're out and
you're not used to that you have to
motivate yourself to go to that library
you got to motivate yourself to build
here and he enjoyed like I said the
structure and the scheduling in time you
know what I'm lunch here I'm this here
I'm this here is there any part of you
that that misses anything of it I do
miss the structure you do but in my life
I'm a structured guy if you go to are
you before prison even with the cocaine
problems I could look in there and tell
you I was very structured I knew if I
made up my mind to rob your house next
Thursday it was gonna get robbed next
Thursday like I knew if I had to go case
a joint on the Tuesday at 12:00 and it
was gonna be a long walk I still went
encased adjoint is that all that stuff
in any year journals
no I didn't write back that no this time
I was opposed to last - you know I've
been doing the journal for I'm talking
bout those cocaine years the last two
cocaine years you said you got those but
I have the journals from 95 do you to
2019 right now oh holy [ __ ] I missed
there's only two years of the missing
2006 and 7 because they got taken in a
car so they hold that got to'd but
pretty much I got to rap to look him
over again
there's nights that you could see the
coke mid-page you can see the writing
going downhill like they gonna be
repeating myself me talking about [ __ ]
that I would talk to somebody else about
the [ __ ] back to your questions drugs
are under structured I'll tell you what
I miss I miss I missed the friendships I
man believe it not birds of a feather
flock together there's two or three
people from 1988-89 that I truly do miss
Delaine I wish they were part of my
circle Torrey Powell's was a [ __ ] i
straight-up
roll encryption over here shot killed
flat seven [ __ ] and had them all the
[ __ ] bran there was a six-figure car
God was [ __ ]
I miss Han Tuan Spencer Spencer Antoine
he's probably dead he was my age when I
met him this is dirty Israel and I'd
like to Rican like well a guy named John
Clark who was uh he was a speculator
jew-hater live all the [ __ ] like he
hated everybody [ __ ] [ __ ] Jews tykes
he hated everybody but he had genuine
love for me is respect and we would hang
out at night together and talk about the
allergy and why he thought that it was
just me inhibitor room and then every
Monday he would get a visitation and his
girlfriend would put a bubble in her
mouth a balloon would speed it
and then him and I would do a few lines
on Monday and we go kiss somehow it she
passed that she just make out mom and
then he slider a little done there is
month
some people swallow the balloon and wait
and finish it out
this was minimum-security he would put
it under his toggle on the way out they
would serve paddle down
I genuinely missed that guy because he
said something really interesting to me
well one thing we're all outside there
was him of the black guy and they said
that this black guy was a badass
[ __ ] not to Spencer hands while
he was just I forget what his name was
me and the librarian were about to do
ahead of us and John Clark was with us
and I said Johnny I'm the speed because
if we do the speed we'll get the [ __ ]
look at the ass
cooking quicker you don't say any of you
do where the acid to do a speed of all I
the speed before it goes right and tell
you has it we're gonna be up all [ __ ]
night when we have [ __ ] up and John
goes give me a few minutes let me walk
around the house a few people and the
black guy looked at me he was super cool
he goes
think about if you guys put as much
effort into doing something positive
instead of this [ __ ] what you
[ __ ] could come up with and
that one resonated in my head how much
thought in those days I put towards
finding a drug deal on how much I stir
you know three hours a day so how am I
gonna get $40 right what pigeon isn't me
give me 40 homes today oh [ __ ] we left a
watch over at the [ __ ] podcast office
that's good
next time I see what he's like I think I
lost my man I haven't seen it
that shit's crushed up snorted we have
to we have a good time snort you [ __ ]
watch you know it really it doesn't
surprise me that great things happen to
me comically when I got off the cocaine
because it freed up my mind of three
hours a day it's like being involved
with a bad relationship
you walk around focusing on that bad
relationship so it doesn't let other
energies that you have gone
grow it stunt you that's why the first
time you smell something weed you gotta
go because this affects all your levels
of creativity and stuff well that guy
said that to me I knew he was on to
something but I I missed I missed all
that stuff I miss but they want sweet
something about like are you gonna let a
crack crack head I'll hustle you was at
you just saw one recently it was always
like that's a great point like this
crack has out there today are some
people is gonna happen EADS his drugs he
I'm not a crack today give me a guy that
doesn't have a zero in the bank and you
give me a guy that's got money and tell
this guy that look yourself three
[ __ ] things I want you to sell three
bottles of water for me on the phone we
give you a lot of cash at the end of the
day Jim five bucks hunger does a lot of
things yeah hunger really motivates you
no need my eggs in yes need need
motivates you know I had leads and I had
addictions and the journey wins and when
I was in 95 let's go back to 95 when I
really wanted to strive with cavity
I had already accepted the drug habit
and had it pay 635 with my child support
and the rest one of my nose 400 was rent
and the rest of my nose the car I had
didn't have a chance again insurance we
got a car yeah
insurance is for suckers I didn't do
another no secondary market thing you
know like nothing like it's so we and
how the transfer of addiction is correct
and real I took the transfer of that
addiction to coke and I really turned it
into a comedy addiction yeah that fueled
I was always an addict economy to do
what we do you have to gone yet no you
never be a comedy 20 quit
jump off a building yeah when you wake
up in the morning if you're pissing and
you're not asking yourself where you're
getting on stage this is not for you you
know if you're pissing and going you
know I can't wait to do three spots
tonight
and you're not even worried about money
because you know there's no money that's
right there's no more I love when people
come up to me cause the money in the
beginning what not all watch I'm gonna
do it make money okay they pick up two
gigs for 200 and they go pick down the
pizza a little because know I could
hustle this guy for 5,000 you probably
could one time but you'll never get
another gig again cuz you're not worth
the [ __ ] adoration you'll get one you
ain't coming back so it was really weird
how I think the transfer of you know
what addiction I gave up to become a
comic was action junkie what do you mean
I was in action Chuck you were enough
like adrenaline [ __ ] I like me they I
wanna like being the underdog okay I
like Bill burr
yeah and how magic I looking for me like
I was that type of [ __ ] like I
dare those two guys walk up my steps
like I loved Brendan shop looking for me
like I was that type of guy like that's
it stuff that motivated me how Brendan's
looking for me when he's bringing Rogan
now I'll know there's one on the fly off
that [ __ ] about it before they even
open looking probable to tackle that guy
I'm in the beam I was nineteen ninety
one or two I just gotten out of prison I
had been married and divorced and I had
a beef with a white guy sweet Oliver
white that there's not a day that his
name is Ryan Cahoon I see here I meet
heart of a guy in Boulder Colorado I
knew him I knew his girlfriend and then
August in the old days they'd be a a
wheat shortage in Colorado believing
that it was the harvest so from the end
of July to the third week of August
there was nothing nothing and I hadn't
had pot in three [ __ ] days and I gave
him like 800 bucks to go to Montana to
get weed from his brother he made some
story up I he was something that we've
his brother this is me you were me lying
you comes to me like a man I'll give you
whatever you want and go Joe and get you
half a pound split it with me just give
me 800 whoa you told me you're coming
back Sunday you know I'm once you told
me son
lunch you're gonna be back believes the
white dude he went fishing with his
father they had to go eat cheddar cheese
and you know get drink lemonade and do
the national anthem he didn't come back
though Wednesday there was no cell
phones in that day I called his wife I
got his father's number do I go with my
800 in the week he knows what are you
talking about I told you Joey I go don't
come back cuz I'm gonna kill you he's
like how you talking to me like that I'm
shooting the house right now I'll never
forget me being separated [ __ ] and all
types of havoc I was already in calmly
like six or seven months I started the
condo and I was cooking something in the
kitchen and I saw him coming up my
stairs and he goes then I go and I had a
stack of knives behind me and I took the
biggest kitchen knife and I walked
towards the door and he didn't even run
down the stairs he jumped and he kept
calling me why you do this to me I go
you [ __ ] you don't ever talk to
me that way you know you supposed to be
his Sunday I don't even know why I'm
telling you the story that was the type
of person I was like I was that person
that's why I don't like having weapons
around me you know I I loved people
looking for me I love them I love you
said you were in actions I love Ryan
Sickler finding out that I robbed let's
see what oh you got all five okay yeah
now well now we're going to do because
guess who I'm sitting over here with I
got Mike Ronnie over there and I got
three other guys that two of their
parents are connected and the other guys
connected politically so what do you
want to do take the loss next time plan
ahead
don't go eat dinner with your stupid
girlfriend when you got two ounces of
coke in your house who does that yeah
does another Friday night Friday nights
are not for girlfriends to the south
cocaine you want to go eat dinner I had
one of my way they saw you over there
and I wasn't kicked in your back door
cuz I have waiters everywhere are the
pride waiters bartender so I will call a
bar and go who's down there
all sick was there really oh my god
Tom's away from him on his way
I'm the way I'd Rob your house and when
I get there the money that I rob from
you outside my folks know I'd buy
coaching you so you came to me a next
day and said somebody robbed my house
last night what are you talking about
hos are you all night last night didn't
I buy you drinks yeah but you're the
only fee for the neighborhood dog I was
with you so for eight years I had you
scratching you had them and once a while
I sent them a message on Facebook like I
just said one thought about six months
ago a guy robbed from a half once's come
back he was buying hot Sony Trinitron
some less he would give us a gram of
coke then one night there in Ozzy
Osbourne he was cute is like a nighttime
only give him yeah really okay
I gave him like six months went over his
house what to do blow we went to buy it
I had told him I had to do something
take a piss I left the bathroom window
open and went back dr. Koch as I was
leaving my brother was coming in guy
that I lived with in fact we hugged I
said I'll see you later we left that
idiot went to New York for some club me
and my buddy waited for him to leave I
crawled in the house stole his half
ounce of coke and his money we partied
all weekend long guess this ready for
this me and my brother the guy I bumped
into in that apartment lifting weights
Monday wit stinky and I haven't told
Mike that I robbed this Mikey guy and
then not another door
[Music]
I don't know forget us lifting weights
and the guy yelling at my brother for
robbing him he thought he did he thought
he didn't stinking the bag he comes back
what the [ __ ] wrong with Mike Mullica
he [ __ ] thinks I robbed him what the
[ __ ] is up with that
I wouldn't rob them I told them I was
and they looked at me goes you rob them
you [ __ ]
because I always take the blame because
of you the only thing I don't miss about
prisoners what prison is intended to do
its intended to break your men on the
way out of me there's no word for this
two of the worst feelings I've ever had
in my life was picking up your child's
he has another man's cologne on when you
get separated mmm okay there's no worse
feeling than that
there's getting kicked in the balls is
finding your while being [ __ ] in the
ass by a [ __ ] when you come home for
Christmas with presents and there's a
little [ __ ] with a big head [ __ ]
your wife that just PTSD z run over ten
minutes why he she just you know there's
certain things in life finding your
mother on the floor dead find your
father on the floor dead finding a
sibling commit suicide these are things
that your heart in your mind never get
over this there's always gonna be a what
are the Hindus quality Aquos chakras the
chakras won't connect right so you have
an imbalance you know a man waking you
up
that's not your father I don't know if
anybody that listens to this or you
either you grew up with a father that
sorry Lee get up it's not a nice feeling
I know a lot of kids at their fall just
woke them up by get up get up it's 8
o'clock and they turn the light on where
I come from you turn my [ __ ] lying on
I take the bed you die that's not I
wouldn't do that to anybody
Lee we got to go we got a room you know
we got or whatever but for me to go into
Lee's room turn the light on it take his
[ __ ] bed and you'll get up your sack
piece of [ __ ] that does something to
your psyche that goes forever so
nobody's waking you up with a good
morning they're waking you up negative
Taylor I know why do you talk like that
I do that enough to six years that's
what you used to get waking up there so
that's why when you get that out into
the world you can't have everybody's
against you because for six years I've
been kicking your bed turn it on the
line on and hit you back with a police
stick and when we makes a joke like come
on man
ten more minutes get the [ __ ] up you fat
sack of [ __ ] now your legs are this
thick how do you wake up
no good mood there's no good mood yeah
who walk in ready to kill somebody I did
not like that about prison I understood
right away that that was the main goal
of prison to break your manhood down so
you never have a kid succeed again you
didn't never succeed again if you don't
see what that and I tell you the first
degrees I couldn't deal with I was
already playing I'm taking that stick
and showing it up it's a bucket ha ha ha
I'm just taking the beating no do it
tonight for the rest of my life yeah or
every place I go to those large you're
gonna go not to kick my bed because I'll
take a lot of [ __ ] high that's look
at the anger in you
I'm not an angry guy like that but just
the thought at that time when men could
come in and go lights out and turn your
TV off you know big Papi's come at the
back the bases are loaded
you bet cichlid carne the [ __ ]
cigarettes that you're saying yeah and
also some [ __ ] guy comes and he goes
hey you sexy [ __ ] bedtime you're like
come on one more time say another
[ __ ] word that won't turn this
[ __ ] on tomorrow you white
[ __ ] you were nothing other
white [ __ ] want to say nothing
get the bed and you gotta see how the
black prisoners the black guards tricked
the black prisoners shut the [ __ ] you
love you little [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ]
was feed when you and you were living in
that bridge or your [ __ ] nappy added
parents I mean damn it's it's a system
yeah that's what I don't that's what I
don't miss that man what I am billeted
on and there's no rehabilitation it's
meant to break you so you have that you
know I'm moving to Colorado I'm going
home and going I'm leaving my buddy's
gonna wait you don't I'm like I'm living
around [ __ ] I'm surrounding my
[ __ ] everybody says good morning and
then I'll start laughing that's because
you're at a city where [ __ ] people a
night I say good morning [ __ ] skank
ass [ __ ]
it's really weird the little things that
you pick up them limp especially now
that I'm over I see why those things
happen
why certain things didn't happen you
know it's pretty interesting how comes
back in the play comes back a little axe
you down the line but I did lose I
replaced the action junk the addiction
with the Charlie action you know the the
whole from the cocaine addiction moved
on to a marijuana addiction which I've
always had and they nobody died and as
far as I know I don't want any - so I
try to take those addictions and move
them down the nicotine addiction issue
the nicotine tone you know it's a
transfer addiction if you need to
transfer addiction this is how to do it
I don't want you to stop I'd rather ride
sick would be happy I'd rather ride sick
let's say you know what seven days a
week I must chew nicotine gum and on
Sundays I'm gonna smoke a cigar I want
you to be happy
I don't smoke reefer cuz I get blasted
anymore
I did a bunk it's on the way I looked
any different you got no no yeah I don't
get it relax and we can we roll the
joint
there's no you brought us some joints
it's it let me
it lets me hold on to my past it's my
teddy bear from back before I'm not in a
decent person it lets me know I'm still
a dirty [ __ ] that's it still lets me
know you know I stop shop with me I
would always shop with one she just
amazing skills oh right what the last
time you shoplift how old how old yeah
how old I get him one time those words
would you get laughs you got a Rob
isis-controlled stores
you're not clipless em sometimes I take
a protein bar like I'll buy two but
still one of my that's the [ __ ] move
I don't live my I put like a magician in
here right in front of him at the
counter back in the day remember when
cigarettes weren't behind the counter oh
yeah and my buddy had them that was his
move he'd walk in he grabbed two packs
of Marlboros well from a distance you
can't see
I'm a he took he just knows he took a
pack and then he would walk around the
store he'd get a big gulp he you know
what I ain't get me cigarettes and he
pulled one pack back and take quite a
big gulp boom out of there with a pack
of cigarettes and it worked and every
[ __ ] time until they moved him behind
their damn psychology there really is a
psychology to shoplifting and it was
crazy I was talking about some of this I
really got there was a time when bic
lighter released football lighters this
had to be mm mmm every [ __ ] team had
a lighter yeah and I was [ __ ] hell
bent for leather I was gonna get a
routine I will call my wife right now
every team you're gonna still 32
[ __ ] like 7-eleven on curse on
and sunset across from the old bar there
and the old we bought all the books
Samuel French yeah the same and friends
that's growing there buy a soda they
used to have a company that used to make
bagels with cream cheese a tomato and
turkey [ __ ] village they sounds a
list and I would get the swirl bread I
love their what they have a brand of
black and white bread challah and it's
like a cake I think I'm cake okay okay
you never just see the problem as people
shoplifting they shoplift you have to
buy the more I buy the more I shop by 20
how much beastie on the 2020 but I
remember going is funny the guy would
watch me I knew he was watching and I'd
do the same thing I take two packs I
love cinnamon search cinnamon certs I'll
just keep the whole box that's all I got
on a plane when they were inedible I
hate the whole pack and I didn't know
that when used to doing edibles -
cinnamon reverse and makes your whole
body feel like you took them just a pill
that you take magnesium and when you
take it it opens your pores and you your
skin star system it makes you sweat from
you
entire package insurgency two or three
of them you know saying so I would go
with that 7-eleven store him while he
was ringing me I'd be taking lighters
Cowboys charges
Ram you got the Ravens and the Ravens
and I would take him home when I had a
hat I put him in that and I had a draw
and then that hat at one time I must had
[ __ ] 60 or 70 80 bins double why this
out most children don't think either you
have like you have like flank tampa bay
buccaneers I don't give a [ __ ] if I got
a tablet babies don't steal the doubles
there for us if there was like three
teams I couldn't get my hands on but
every other team I got my hands on the
[ __ ] tremendous I'm a bit still going
in there one day and just picking up to
hold you how they will put trained tre
yeah yeah I just took the whole tray and
walked out of it and the guy said way
you go alright gotta worry about you
bothering me go get some Sam you would
solve me the fact that you want to come
over with those dry skin oh my god oh no
I used to kill those people
and one time I robbed my claim to fame
is so we in it's so weird what when you
look back in your life like I was
worthless I knew I had no future but I
used to go to this liquor saw this
jewelry store when I was 20 and 21 20 20
19 and I was just going man I was a
broke kid I missed my mother and I was
gone there she liked jewelry and I just
going in look at the bracelets and stuff
it was more of a white jewelry store
wasn't like a human jewelry store they
have a different type of jewelry then
one day I just asked the lady can you
show me those rings and she took the
tray out she put it down she walked away
walked away yeah thank you
just walked away so I was there one day
they had the same rings in the slots so
I just took a ring I sat that way if I
to come back on of these two expensive
and I may believe I scratched my leg and
I slipped a ring
my sweats out had shorts on I left that
was interesting what the gold store
don't pay you that's why I love these
people like I'm gonna go saw my diamond
watch look yeah I just tried to sell
hold engage you're getting back this guy
said let me tell you something yeah
if you private sale it you can get 3,500
I'll give you $800 yeah so [ __ ] you
don't get a visit from my daughter it
means nothing nothing you turn it upside
down you see a little black hand with a
Jew signal those little [ __ ] blood
diamonds via Africa via Israel so what
do you think [ __ ] is the point you
think South Africans gonna get both
diamonds oh no hell no make it big time
is real guys that come with those Jew
hats with the big emerald over here like
they run a lodge they show up they get
black mulatos whatever they tight little
ropes around their waist and they drove
into that cave the lead they stick a
thing of dynamite like they did the
Chinese people in the 40s when they
built the railroads they would take a
[ __ ] and throw them over to [ __ ]
collision with a strap taunt the
dynamite you think I'm kidding here no
that's how they built the train I mean
as the Chinese built the trains in this
country yeah oh yeah a lot of people
don't know that there are Italians were
there but the Chinese did but yeah so
sorry
just this Jewish girl was called Michels
Jewish it's 37 years ago of all
limitations is done plus it's suspended
I've called Miguel's now you know the
same like two months later I went again
did the same trick took a ring same lady
they had three little different old
ladies but no alarm on the buzzer no
buzzer on the door come on yeah I've
been a thousand jewelry stores of my
mother growing up there's always a
buzzer on the door no buzzer I waited a
month I went in there one day this
summer with a football jersey
there was a Burger King down the corner
so I go to Burger King get a chicken
sandwich like
the street to go burrows and get a
batino than my main a papaya milkshake
cuban-style
I would finish it that would give me
balls and then walk right in there and
steal something so one day she drops a
tray
- they were all engagement rings I'm
like I'm thinking I might get engaged
she just what a great time of the year
you know she drops off a tray of [ __ ]
engagement bands I give her some idiot
comes in hi I'm looking for wristbands
okay and she just leaves me that this
time I said [ __ ] one or two I picked up
my shirt rings under there the whole
[ __ ] the whole [ __ ] train just ran
the [ __ ] out of it but I'm the run out I
saw they had a tray on the camera you
could spin spin and had gold chains and
bracelets this is a very weird thing to
say but I plan on robbing down I was
just saving it for a rainy day
September 13th 1982 opening game
Pittsburgh against Dallas in the heat of
their rivalry I'm one then I [ __ ] more
Dallas at home I don't know how I was
gonna lose at home on a Monday night you
got a better chance of your mom getting
raped by ten black guys from Terre Haute
Indiana she was a [ __ ] Ventura County
you're saying like they gonna leave turn
off they quit Columbia House and they
take a train they probably weren't
Columbia House in Terre Haute Indiana
that's the chances are you got of
anybody being Dallas on a Monday night
it's very wanted to Dallas and whoop
them I put the bed in with camel breath
he was my teacher at the time we had we
had graduated high school he was still
cool it save me put in the [ __ ] four
thousand dollar bet with you if you
don't pay they're gonna come for you
yeah I can't do that sick Lori's one
since I was your criminal and I thought
about that gold train thing and I went
down I had walked like walk the streets
and I saw how I was gonna do it what I
needed you know what guys I could use I
was running out of there with that gold
chain there it's like the spindle with
all I'm hanging all right and yet bow
yeah it's out
I'm gonna do it I have the attorney
friend of mine I asked him what would I
get in trouble for he said grand theft
and I grant that grand larceny
arson and other [ __ ] but you'll be out
in [ __ ] two weeks I said fine I
[ __ ] got up that Thursday morning
which if it was the 13th 14 15 16 it was
a 16th of September look it up 19 he
opening season opening game 1982 look
who it was Monday night Monday Night
Football
Steelers Cowboys Cowboys you November
see I'm talking this is when they
hilarious that would be this is this is
when Monday nights were I don't know
what the score was but I know they went
into Dallas and beat the [ __ ] out of it
1981 80 82 83 footballs NFL season
Monday night schedule Sunday September
12
give me Monday the 13th look I even
remember what day it was
Pittsburgh Dallas we're at Dallas come
on come on the final score I don't know
36:28 Pittsburgh Pittsburgh was given
seven I mean 36 you know a lot this is
up on the Cowboys this is Oh back then
this is yeah like first of all they were
given seven and then when you call the
bookie it dropped to five Oh big mistake
that's what we turned around and
high-five everybody we got this sucker
oh yeah do it live by 7:00 if that was
its it dropped what's the wind right we
didn't know why it was a Dallas minus
five and a half over 42 what the [ __ ] do
you people think I could drop all week
it was seven and it dropped to five and
look they gave me the hook you know to
really let you know that we're gonna
[ __ ] you in the ass
so me and three of my buddies were like
let's bet it four ways and we better for
ways we watch we got a grandma called
must you put down I think we bet 2,000
to win 2400 Alice yeah we had Dallas in
the under what came in the over right
yeah we got born losers 36:28 for losers
losing with a tattoo and I had all four
of us [ __ ] three [ __ ] we've had
2,000 honey over two thousand nine
dollars in two thousand dollar parlay
Dan six also we got to come up with 50
something hundred dollars and the
Cowboys almost came back to it says oh
yeah we almost came back but it wasn't
an that we I was there I guess the duck
was there 82 who's as a stall buyer who
is a very linear white Danny white baby
yeah anyway and then Bradshaw with
certain everything's money when you can
will you remember every mother made for
dinner yeah what brought chicks you
remember every bad [ __ ] I love
everything I cannot get over you your ml
that Thursday I got up I told my buddy
Timmy Holloway that Friday night that
Thursday like I'm Brett he stole my
buddy we spoke last night to me I want
and he put me to the test cuz I was the
one listening tomorrow I robbed this day
I had three friends at the time they're
as responsible as I was but at that time
they had mothers they had fathers had
families they were going places you know
my odds of going places what that time
not much I wasn't going anywhere
I was just waiting to get off I was just
swimming in the water thinking life was
a [ __ ] joke I would put bets and what
bookmakers and tell him to suck my dick
this guy in high school there was this
guy before the bowl like $1000 this guy
I ducked him like we were friends and
one day I put a bet him with him and I
ducked them for years
no no idea I ducked him for my three
weeks and when they saw me playing
basketball and he pulled over with a
[ __ ] chain like a real chain and he
goes either you have like 220 hours I'm
gonna start whipping you with this
[ __ ] chain before my friends came
home and said look
you ain't do nothing this will take the
chain from me and [ __ ] you up because
I'm coming back in a couple days
guess what that dude killed himself
before he could ever come back I was
like wolf like I knew I had nothing
going for me so I didn't want to tell my
friends I just told Timmy I go till he
pick me up at 9:00 in the morning I'm a
little Rob Michael's Julis tomorrow I
called my friend stinky we picked him up
against his will he's one of the guys
that doesn't talk to me today yeah which
why would he write that I'm very calm
stinky and and the robbing the jewelry
store without a gun at 10:00 in the
morning in broad daylight and all that I
ran and it's as [ __ ] up as it sounds
it's what let me know I could do
something with my life like it let me
know okay I'm not gonna be an
archaeologist I'm not gonna be a doctor
I'm not gonna be a lawyer but I can be a
damn pity cuz I already planned this all
by my own and got away playing out where
that was the worsen that kind of at me
and then I got away with it because my
own town was corrupt
the owner was the owner was like one
wrong picked up if he gets arrested he
goes he does ten years but he has to pay
me restitution
I'm not looking for a restitution so
they only paid off the cops they dropped
off the investigation he's like there's
an insurance money
lolly is one insurance and everybody
[ __ ] luck now yeah he must have put
in there that was worth two million
right here exactly so I saw him two
years after he hugged me other guests a
[Laughter]
lot of times and you think about your
life and the lessons you learn you know
I can't I don't know I mean I guess
everyone she's a different person but
the idea that you liked having people
looking for you and loved it
that good so what changed when he went
to prison he fall asleep cause you can
finally relax like what you said you
could finally relax and president so it
seemed like either at a certain point
you stopped liking it not that I stopped
liking it it was
just that that was it I was caught the
game was always gonna have to do that
again I mean don't get me wrong
hour and a half after I walked out of
that halfway house I was back between
prison and a half whale come on
they let me loose from the prison and
told me to get myself to the halfway
house yeah hook me up let's stop and get
in a ball and drop me off at the
half-way because whatever level you walk
in with you have to work backwards okay
so in between the halfway house they're
not responsible for I smoked and talked
so when they finally pitched me why you
just came from where we rehabbed Fortas
family and you it's like you did coke
three days ago now that was four years
ago so they start from there you know I
was the only person I was counting was
myself Ryan yeah that's right you know
the second one somebody tells you I'm
shooting a Netflix I'm shooting a
special to tell Netflix good luck you're
gonna walk into that place and saw me
especially you tape the [ __ ]
Chattanooga it's some [ __ ] bar with
some band in the back playing Sweet Home
Alabama Wells's going on your life
brother now right now I'm just being a
dad outside a comedy and everything I'm
just being a dad I'm trying to be a
better dad I mean I'm a good dad but I
want to be a better dad you know I grew
up I grew up by default without a dad
because my dad died when I was 16 you
talk about going back to the [ __ ] you
won't shake and changes you as a person
we found her dead dad dead in his bed
and then shortly after that we had to
move in with our mother she left us we
were we were my brothers and I raised
ourselves she would come home once a
week to do laundry we wouldn't see her
after that and then moved in with my
dad's mom when she kicked us out of the
house and then she dropped dead in front
of me I'm giving her CPR mouth-to-mouth
I mean that [ __ ] I'm dealing with it
right now
it's mortalities what I think about a
lot now especially being a parent and
I'm in I go to therapy I went I went the
doctor Drew told me to go see somebody
he's like it's specific and there's an
end to it's not just talking to someone
it's called a DMR
and you know talk therapy you just got a
box of [ __ ] in your head and you open
that lid and you just pull things out
and then when that's done you put them
back in there and you go about your [ __ ]
but this for lack of a better
explanation is a type of therapy where
when that stuffs out it's like we're not
gonna put that back in about we'll move
that [ __ ] over here we're gonna put that
over in the garage you know you don't
need to deal with that you don't need to
deal with it you know and figure out a
different way to think about your [ __ ]
and then you'll be able to understand it
better so I'm I've been a month in on
that and it's been pretty [ __ ]
interesting and you just just from
talking she'll sit and listen to me do
you want to know what I heard this hour
and then she'll lay it out and she'll go
I go all and then her mom's my mom and I
might you know and you start putting
yourself in these positions of who you
are now and you you know all of its
rooted in childhood you know you worry
about being a good parent cuz you didn't
have one sometimes you're over correct
but I'm pretty [ __ ] even killed I'm
relaxed with her I don't yell my
daughter I don't raise my I don't try
not to raise my voice so I get a little
bit I'm like that's enough like that she
played me though one night it was one
day long she wasn't listening to her mom
we're all walking in the grocery store
and her mom's telling her to listen
she's not listening I finally turn
around said hey that's enough and she
hid behind her mom's legs but she hid
like I beat the [ __ ] out of my kid he
said I Monica parents saw that started
looking I was like uh-uh we ain't having
any of that [ __ ] here that's that's
[ __ ] right there how old is your
daughter this will be five in October do
you see the gap that you fill in their
life oh yeah is it just when you own
again I'm not trying to be rude to
anybody
we're in the comedy game and a good guy
came on this podcast once it alerted me
tonight was you're enough he doesn't
he's a musician Rudy Sarzo he said that
you have to assume it's true
I mean 50% of us that are doing this
together friends we have luggage oh we
have luggage as mental issues thought
were hard I've accepted it you know yeah
except at these things
look there's something wrong here's the
thing there's something off with that
with any every comedian the fact that
you want to get up make a roomful of
strangers laugh that's not normal
I'm off but it's it's off in a beautiful
way you know it's it's taking this
trauma that's what my podcast is all
about you come on it's taking I say
highlighting the lowlights the
honeydew's you're taking all this
negative [ __ ] that happened to you and
even through the tears and the anger and
the frustration the anxiety the stress
or whatever you're still finding a
moment to figure out where that [ __ ]
funny is in there and that's what I
appreciate about comedians I think I
have more even more appreciation sitting
down week after week listening to these
people take their [ __ ] dark trauma
and spin it into to funny and and just
like wow and it's a different way to
look at something than curling up in the
corner and crying or him self-medicating
or any of that so you know she's five
she knows she look she's gonna hear all
these podcasts I'm not good I can't lie
to my kid I can't ever lie to my
daughter about drugs drinking my way we
grew up now it's all on me so I'll just
do is listen so I think honestly I've
always told her mom if anything ever
[ __ ] happens to me you ever listen to
the podcasts she'll know who her real
father is
god I write to my daughter you do I have
a journal I would do Johnny a fella yeah
and everyone's gray days I write what
I'm feeling in the morning one of the
feeling at night what she learned for
the day I've been right here for about
three years I want her to read these
when I'm dead you know I want her to
hear about my daughter from me I wanted
to hear about the kidnapping from me I
want her to hear about all these things
from me in time right right huh I'm just
what she's reading is because when
you're with your child whether it's a
boy or a girl you just it's I love to do
a show about raising my daughter but at
the same time getting flashbacks to what
I was doing I know well all the time
beneath the Planet of the Apes
that came on 19 Saturday that makes me
officially with a red lie and not seven
years [ __ ] long I was born February
19 1963 I saw up beneath the Planet of
the Apes in the movie theaters and
without some doubt supervision me and
three other [ __ ] lunatics on the
block told my mother where we gonna be
playing in the alley and we disappeared
for two hours to go see beneath aplenty
if they take this get off yeah oh the
Statue of Liberty on the beach tipped
over and all that that movie sent me for
a loop but just the fact that my mother
didn't know where the [ __ ] I was for two
and a half hours gets me angry
yup but then again it shows the spunk I
had by having the balls to go to the
movie theater so when I said with my
daughter that she's reading a dinosaur
book on my lap I don't know what the
[ __ ] she's staying about and Tyler just
she like that but it's interesting
because I'm filling that void but we
talked to a lot of comics and we talked
with contact with a lot of women that I
thought yeah you ever talk to a hot hot
woman comic no you could [ __ ] her if you
tried but at the same time you know
you're not gonna get there because it's
damaged goods you're not putting it down
I have a lot of female friend comics but
I can tell they're damaged goods and I
can tell where the damage comes from you
know yeah like with me for years I
blamed everything on my mother guess
what it wasn't my mother's death
uneffective miasma the father's death
affected me and three because I didn't
know anything that's right
till this day Lorne only thing so that's
why I write in that book for her yeah
she's gonna listen to podcasts mm where
there's 2,000 of us but I also wanted to
read when I side of the story without
the jokes without the opinions just this
is what happened nobody else is
different
nobody else should tell you different
you know I think I'm gonna cut the drug
use down that's the only thing I'm gonna
cut down a little bit I don't want her
to grow up thinking that her hero did
drugs
we're our kids heroes oh yeah every time
they hear us where's my god for hunger
I'm hollow from last night that goes
into a little head every time you hear
well we're gonna take you over to Lee's
house you're gonna play with Madeline
while me and the parents are gonna go
out drinking party night they hear that
when you trick a bow in front of your
son he sees that yeah well my daughter
smells marijuana in the bathroom I know
that you know I'm saying so I wanna
eliminate the drug use the drug talk to
later on so she gets I wanted to get my
youth I wanted to understand my mother's
death when I went through those five
years of being lost you know there's so
many things that that's what's great
about parenting but the simple thing of
all of it is and you said it it's just
be there be there that's it shut your
don't need a [ __ ] trip to Europe and
all phases and we're taking cruises
great there just be it the [ __ ] games
and show that you're interested that's
it that's it that is [ __ ] it no they
look you you lost your father at 3:00 I
lost mine at 16 I can tell you that it
wouldn't have mattered if I lived in a
palatial mansion it would have made that
feel any better would it doesn't matter
how much [ __ ] money we had or cars it
would have hurt just as bad and none of
that would have helped or [ __ ] matter
none of it none of it made any
difference so just being there and
showing a genuine interest is all you
[ __ ] really need to do just you're
are imperfect you know you a Minneapolis
last week how was it
I sent you that picture yeah on the wall
there great man Rick and Tammy have
great clubs up there that's great nice
hotel
yeah great hotel you know everything a
lot more yeah and I'm gonna go back I'm
gonna show in Baltimore September 14th
we're right at it's called the famous
it's these guys man they're Jimmy's
famous seafood so they hurt me old rogue
and they sent me this [ __ ] Baltimore
care package crab cakes crab dip crab
crab crab crab crab and I said well [ __ ]
man when I come Coco's any good what's
that Coco's and Baltimore any good
co-ceo crab house
oh that's uh see you know I think you
talk about good yes they state mailed to
you yeah but this guy said the same
thing send it out a matter of fact I got
a four dozen and eight crab cakes coming
this Saturday to my buddies in Temecula
I'm taking my daughter down to go I know
yeah how fresh are they they're fresh
man they're fresh so I take her back and
I say just as a thank you I'm gonna come
in and have dinner there well invite
family for an it thirty people show up
just to come see me and hang out his
place and he ended up being in Greece
and the time this is like 5:00 in the
morning this dude is [ __ ] his name is
John I'm in a dog what's the name of
this restaurant IMI's famous seafood
I'll give you all the info yeah I
promise you great crab cakes
dude the best and and it's not just crab
cake they got jumbo Stumpf crab stuffed
shrimp I'm telling you I'll show you so
I go in and he's calling me to make sure
me and my family are say he's in greeks
calling to make sure we're - are they
taking care of you - I said yeah yeah so
he said they're gonna take you on a
little tour of the spot after and then
we're gonna take your picture and put
you on the wall of fame and I the wall
of fame and there's the rock every
[ __ ] rave in any and if I mean it's
big time people so they take me upstairs
and it's a full now when I was a kid we
would go there every now and then to
grab crab cakes and leave because my
aunt lived in Highland town and there
right on the edge of the city and it
used to just be their house and you know
didn't get permits or anything their dad
built this [ __ ] restaurant and they
took it to the next level so they're
doing tailgates they're doing but you
know if when when Rogan came to town
they had they had a pre-party at their
restaurant and then you could pay by you
it included a ticket a meal drinks and a
bus ride over to the arena and back so
you could tailgate there they throw the
biggest tailgate I'm gonna be when I go
back and bought in September at Reid's
gonna host this when that's my favorite
football player ever so I get to hang
out with every meet ed Reed so I go
upstairs and they show me this [ __ ]
event room and I was like you gotta be
[ __ ] this is a comedy corset see it
seats 200 with tables or 300 no tables
but he's like I'll give you a hundred
percent of the door but let me keep the
tables
so I can make my money right here he put
it along people staying no it's
separated off it's got its own bar in it
its own restrooms in it it is piped for
sound perfectly and they do all the
Ravens events there everything like they
have it [ __ ] down so I said [ __ ] the
other Club won't even book me here in
town why don't you let me do a show here
he's like done so I sold two shows out
and went back last year so this year I'm
already doing one on September 14th so
I'm gonna make it hopefully a yearly or
at least every other year I go back and
do a show there cuz I just love going
back to my hometown and I don't care how
big I get I would love to keep doing a
little show like that you know give back
and keep the ticket prices cheap people
come in they and it's great food so
they're all eating before they come up
there drinking there's no minimums or
anything that you can get up and walk
serve yourself his staff is first-class
I mean it's the [ __ ] [ __ ] so I'm
going back there and and the little spot
is called the famous he calls it the
famous Jimmy so that Club in there it's
called the famous so I go do it like
I've been doing this will be my second
one there I want to keep doing them with
them they're just great people one of
the dates you got coming up I'll be out
with Tom Segura and octo I'm at the ice
house this month the Labor Day weekend
what is it the 31st I think it is a
night me too are you there
7:30 yeah it's - yeah I'm there doing
the main room and then Baltimore
September 14th and then I'm on I'll be
doing some dates with Sakura again but
just go to Ryan Sickler calm it's all
there all the dates will be and the
honeydew how many days a week you're
doing the honeydew is one day a week out
of your mom's house studios the honeydew
podcast.com subscribe check it out it's
all about we sit here and talk about
highlighting the lowlights laughter
always dark what else [ __ ] I love
podcasting cuz every episode is
something different yeah that's what I
love about so I'm not personal coming
here laughs I'll [ __ ] asses off till
we puke you know some of them begin to
serious topics other than we just talk
about one topic that's great to me
that's the best thing about [ __ ]
podcasting man no doubt I'm gonna be on
the Holli due next month again yeah we
only got the age 9 with 47
I'm cover 10 to 14 yeah couple of one
years it was like when I robbed Raul I
robbed shut across the tape in my house
as he was moving in here at he moved in
and I saw him and his family get back in
the truck and leave so made my buddies
went in then robbed them and I had taken
a stereo with two speakers tremendous
Fisher with the components that one
cassette but then guess what me and
[ __ ] Raul became friends so he come
over you know let's go play in your room
with him when we can so free year Ryan
Sickler always a pleasure brother I like
you I love you on my heart there's
anything we could do for you you know
we're here for you and I will definitely
be on the honey due next month before my
Chicago date yeah come on so we could
talk about mine to the ages yeah and
again we'll both be at the Ice House on
the 31st and the only other day that I
got on there is Friday the 13th wash
that [ __ ] and kill your cat I'm at the
Dallas I'm at the Majestic Theater I'm
there with the guys who shot Kennedy
they'll all be there doing a gun display
showing you how they shot him from the
know Lee Busch when they call the grassy
knoll yeah the grassy I took that tour
didn't know Lee but they are taking it
no why would I take because once you get
up in that window you look out that
window you're like there's no you can't
even see a tiny chick giving a tiny
[ __ ] thanks thank you they liked the
guy was Johnny Houdini he had one eye
like a look around the world it's such a
setup and the grassy know as soon as you
walk into every it smells like
Philadelphia today
it smells like gunpowder and blood
[ __ ] people running for their lives
it's a [ __ ] nightmare like I said the
13th at the Lincoln at the Majestic
Theatre in Dallas and this 738 31 with
my man man my main man over in the big
room Sickler and then on the 27th
of September I'm at the Chicago theater
with [ __ ] Dean Delray and just added
Kate Quigley she's gotta had 20 pounds
to a [ __ ] I'm not taking a pussy's to
skim you go to Chicago Chicago women
have big [ __ ] snatches I'm gonna show
up with Kate with that little chin see
how [ __ ] has like a little devil [ __ ]
and she wears those bikinis I'm like
there's no lump in there I want to see
that crab cake what are you gonna stake
it not dantana's but the other place
they put the lump crab mix with the
thing she's got like a [ __ ] inserter
jump I like the yeah what is the place
Ruth's Chris he's crazy yeah I got like
they got like lesbian pants with already
mistletoes what we call those camel toes
and running in places the [ __ ] you call
those things and now for a word from our
sponsors let me talk to you savages
about something all right and this is as
important as can be internet privacy is
dead as we know it that is why I use
Express VPN expressvpn runs the
background of ah no runs in the
background of your computer or your
phone and then you let you use the
internet just like you normally would
you download the app you click to
connect and viola you're protected that
easy it shields your identity no
location tracking and you are totally
totally anonymous you like Joey how do I
get it all right here we go grab a pen
download the expressvpn app on your
computer or phone push one button and
viola bam you're protected I don't even
know how viola is probably follow I'm
crawling 648 280 pounds less than seven
dollars a month with a thirty back
money-back guarantee that's will
expressvpn does alright
like I said Internet privacy is dead
find out how you can get three months
free Joey what are you talking about
three [ __ ] at expressvpn doctor
slash Church grab a pen CH you are CH
that's expressed VP and calm exp ar e SS
VPN dot-com slash Church they're gonna
give you three months free when you buy
you one year package all right
visit expressvpn comm slash church to
learn more and take back your privacy
because listen right now you're sitting
there listening to a podcast and this
little guy with a missing eye somewhere
in a dungeon whacking off to you um
saying what happened to [ __ ] poor
Whitney Cummings don't put no pictures
up alright the podcast is also brought
to you by the best then Sarah watches I
got my aluminium death on right now it's
the anniversary sale it's on guys Ben
Sarah watching is having their biggest
sale of the year right now you might as
well get two or three of them so you
look good October November and New
Year's Eve you walk in there like you
own the joint the more you shop the more
you save
you can literally save hundreds of
dollars and this happens once a year
everything AB in Sarah calm is on sale
nothing is off-limits
then Sarah just dropped two new
collections and a line of men's wallets
are you ready or what and they're all on
sale everything products do sell out do
not wait to buy the holidays or what 130
days away why be a jerk start shopping
now these will make the perfect gift for
your niece nephew or your nephew your
uncle your dad when it comes to watches
this is the best bang for your buck it's
like buying a Subaru you'll you'll never
have this chance to get a Vince arrow
you'll never see watches of this caliber
on sale you can't pass this deal this
good up then Sarah is celebrating their
five-year anniversary they got a lot to
celebrate a rather write over 17,000
five-star reviews so you know that
they're doing something on the right
track if you've been wanting to check
this brand out this is your chance
and there's never
a better time to shop they offer free
shipping worldwide Thailand Hong Kong I
don't care no no more turning the [ __ ]
eggbeater over then cero we'll get you
to watch there they got collections for
men and women and they offer engraving
on select styles so treat yourself was
shop for a gift is what I'm talking
about do me a favor go to Vince ever
watches calm and take advantage of the
great discounts on top of their already
affordable watches the quality the
workmanship you cannot beat it that's
been Sara watches calm then shop their
biggest sale of the year then Cheryl
watches calm vince arrow watches calm I
want to thank Vince arrow
I want to thank expressvpn I want to
thank my cousin's CBD lion doc Tom the
best and I also want to thank in hims
why go bald and lose your heart on go-to
for hims calm right now that's how we do
it it me in Sickler August 31st I'm at
the Chicago at the Majestic Theatre in
Dallas
February 13th it's bad luck then who
gives a [ __ ] hit your mother-in-law in
the head with a ladder you won't have to
walk with me and another 27th or
whatever the [ __ ] daughter's Chicago
Tina and they got tickets on sale for K
quickly dean del rey and myself all
right stay black have a good week and
we'll see you [ __ ] it's nice and
early tip top Magoo Monday morning
August something I don't know what the
[ __ ] the date is I love you guys stay
black check this [ __ ] me Lee